[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - STEVIE WONDER, "PASTIME
PARADISE"]
VEST: I'd like to begin with
a very personal anecdote.
When I was quite young, probably
in first or second grade
or so, we had what,
for me growing up
in a little town
in West Virginia,
was a great adventure.
My parents took my brother
and me to Washington,
our nation's capital.
We went on the bus.
It was a long overnight trip.
They knew I would be
so excited about this,
they didn't tell me until
the morning we left.
And it was really
quite a highlight
of my life to get out and see
the big, exciting city that's
our nation's capital.
On the way, we drove
through a little town
somewhere in Maryland.
And the bus pulled up to a
restaurant to stop and let
people get something to eat.
There was a young black man who,
I suppose looking back on it,
was probably in his
early to mid-20s
carrying his little daughter.
And when we stopped
at that restaurant,
they would not serve him.
And they would not
serve the little girl.
And my mother decided that this
was not a reasonable thing.
And she had heard
what the man had
tried to order for his little
girl, which was a bowl of soup.
So my mother ordered
an extra bowl of soup.
And the waitress of
course, did not refuse her.
But before she handed the
bowl of soup to my mother,
she reached over and just
laden it with pepper.
And that electric
moment has just
always been with me ever since.
And I think that was the time at
which I lost some of my naiveté
about racial relations
in America and so forth.
Looking in a more
pragmatic context,
and I don't think we should
be afraid to be pragmatic,
one also has to recognize
that our society has
the makeup that it has,
and we know perfectly well
within a time frame of
20 years or 30 years
exactly what the racial and
ethnic makeup of this country
is.
And on a pragmatic
scale, we simply
must learn to live, and
work, and advance together.
The historical forces
make it a difficult task.
The current economic forces make
it an even more daunting set
of problems.
But if we are to be a
great nation in the future,
somehow we have to resolve
and come to grips with it.
So I think even in a
pragmatic sense, as well as
a moral sense, we, as a leading
institution of education
and research in the United
States in the 1990s,
must be dedicated to educating
increasing numbers of students
from the various components
of the American population.
We must produce, from those
communities, the leaders
that the nation is going to need
downstream in 20 or 30 years.
So there will be no backing
off of this Institution's
commitment to these
matters despite the fact
that we're in rather
difficult economic times,
it's got to be very,
very high on our agenda.
At the same time,
we must never be
naive about what is involved,
about the depth of effort that
is going to be required.
And as we do with any
student, we win these battles
and make our progression
one individual at a time
by individual's
commitments, by what
we can provide to individuals,
by what we can learn from them.
And I hope as a
leader that I can
play at least some modest
part in inspiring and leading
our community on to undertake
this very important role.
As you know, I have
seen the first video
that was made by our
African American students.
And there was at least
one immediate lesson
in looking at that which
quite honestly surprised
me, and that was the fact
that almost every one
of the students, in talking
about their personal
observations of racial
relations and so
forth on the campus from
their personal perspective,
immediately homed in on the
instructional aspects of MIT.
Almost all of the
anecdotes that they
passed on to the rest of
us had to do with classroom
or other learning situations.
That's very important
for us all to understand.
It certainly is important
for me to understand
as an administrator and
a leader on the campus.
The bad news is
it shows problems
in the most fundamentally
important aspect of what we do.
But the good news
is that's something
that we can
consciously be aware of
and try to work together
as a community to improve.
So I see this as a wonderful
discovery and learning tool.
And I'm very grateful to all
of you who are participating
in the project.
You mentioned the question
of teaching diversity.
I find this a very difficult
concept to grapple with.
I don't know if it is literally
possible to teach diversity
in the sense that one can
teach electronic circuits,
or calculus, or what have you.
My suspicion is that we
must accomplish education
about multiculturalism,
about diversity
in our society and
our activities,
on many different
planes and through
many different mechanisms.
Some, I know, would disagree
with this philosophy.
But I find the subject to be so
broad, and so complex, and so
ill-defined that it
is not clear to me
that one can define
a single course,
or a single curriculum,
that will satisfy
that need for all people.
So I think that we need
to think about diversity,
multiculturalism, understanding
history, and sociology,
and technology, and other
subjects from a broad variety
of cultural and
racial perspectives
in many different ways.
I think we have
to do it formally.
We have to do it informally.
This taping project is
a beautiful example.
Dr. Williams' course
is a good example.
Mel King's course
I think we have to do
this over and over again
in different venues
and different ways
to fit different
people and kind of just
build up an environment
where nobody gets
through the Institute
without some informal, if not
formal, exposure
to a disciplined
thinking about other
cultures, other races.
There is no simple answer.
If I knew it, I
certainly would share it
and try to implement it.
But I think it's a question we
need to keep in front of us.
We need to try a
lot of experiments.
It needs to be part
of what we think
of as the hidden curriculum
at MIT in the same way
that professional ethics
and other things are.
And I hope, over
time, that we can
make some progress together.
SIMONIDES: I'm an
old-timer at MIT.
I'm the old man now.
But I still think of
myself as somebody
who is still exploring and
finding out about the culture.
And one of the things
that I'm finding out
is a series of
paradoxes that operate.
You refer to MIT as a kind of
a arch place for technology,
and for science, and
for the inventive mind.
And that's absolutely true.
It is one of the
important notions
that people have about MIT.
I have a little bit
different picture of MIT.
My picture is one where
there is like a soup
kettle with a lot of things,
different vegetables and so on,
are all bubbling up
and of a fermentation.
And the given, in your
image, or in the metaphor
you made and mine, is brains.
Because the truth is, every
time the MIT door opens,
brains come in, more brains, the
better brains, the new brains.
And so that is a given.
But what happens
inside is really more
of this soup in
the cauldron than
of a well-developed
and rational process.
And the question is, when the
door opens and brains come in,
also a lot of differences, a lot
of different elements come in--
we call it diversity and
we're very much for it,
everybody is these days--
and the question is, how do we
deal with it after it's here?
And how, when we desire it,
how do we bring it about
and how all that
works, and whether it
works to our satisfaction,
to our expectations.
The job I have is an
equal opportunity officer
for the past 13
years, a long time.
It's kind of the
official job of reporting
to the government about
statistics of diversity,
telling the world,
the country, how
we are doing on the issue
of integrating differences
in our community.
And that job is a good job.
That part of my
job is a good job.
MIT is doing well.
We have every year in the
entering class of freshmen,
30% are Asian American.
That's one of the
minorities in this country.
We're doing very well by them.
About 12%, 14% are what we call
under-represented minorities.
We don't have nearly as many.
Here there are still
American minorities-- blacks,
Mexican Americans, Puerto Rican
Americans, Native Americans.
And that's fine.
But when you look
from the inside,
I think the picture in
my job the past 13 years
is it is a job
full of frustration
because we don't anywhere
near succeed in this as
well as we've succeeded
in some other endeavors
that MIT has taken.
Why and how?
We have on the faculty
about 1,000 faculty members.
And we have had something
like, at the highest number,
18 black faculty
members out of 1,000.
And that was about
14, 15 years ago.
We now have between 10 and 12.
So we have gone
backwards in that.
Way back before,
in the '60s, we had
five freshmen, black
freshmen, in the freshman
class coming in.
In '69, in one year,
we brought it up to 55.
And this year, or the past
three or four years, we
have been hovering
between 60 and 80.
What we find is
that we have made
some gains, some dramatic
gains, very positive gains
in the past, and that we're
either stuck in some of them
or even gone backwards.
And so that is a
picture of unsuccess.
And when I talk about
the paradox here,
you have this great
fame and fortune making
kind of society of young minds.
And on the other hand,
you have this kind
of unsuccess of not meeting
what we wish to meet.
The time honored
way, when you want
to get something done
around here, first of all,
you've got to know not to ask
because you may be told no.
It's easier to say I'm sorry
if you fail than to say
may I. So what would
be the experiment
that we would start
here in the MIT spirit?
Well, we've got some
unstructured groups
of colleagues to work together
to talk about our differences.
And we found out that it
was encouraging to people
who came together, but it
was also a little bit weird,
if you will, a little
bit different to ask them
to sit down, maybe one-on-one,
pair them up on the first day,
to talk about what's
different about them
in order to make a bridge
to work together better.
Well, it was awkward,
but it was attractive.
Now why was it attractive?
I think it was because
our premise was probably
a right one, that when you
talk about your differences,
you're talking about
yourself, you bring out,
without much consideration, what
it is that you have deep down,
if you will, perhaps
that you won't even
admit makes you proud.
The thing that you are yourself.
And when you talk about
that, to make it legitimate,
that you should talk about
that with a colleague at work
for the purpose of building a
relation, a connection, if you
will.
It's a paradox because you're
talking about differences.
Differences lead people
to argue, to fight.
People kill each
other on differences.
You don't have to go very far
to read or learn about that
or even see it these days.
And yet, the premise to
talk about differences,
to start with differences in
order to build on them so as
to make connections,
so it makes synergy
and make working together.
We hope that this
kind of program,
that this spirit, if you will,
of success in this environment
for minorities would
exude itself so
that the people that we bring
here, even for visitors,
we will be able to entice.
So now are their excuses?
There are a lot of excuses.
When you don't succeed,
you turn to reasons.
The reasonable people,
people with brains,
are very good with
coming up with excuses.
But still, the problem persists.
And if you're somebody,
like Clarence or myself,
who has to be here and count and
one of the things you ask, you
ask all our fellow
senior officers,
we ask ourselves in our
own areas, every year,
how many appointments
will you make
on the faculty and the staff,
and so that we can talk.
How many do you think
might be minorities?
Well, for the past
decade of my 13 years,
the first 10, what we
got is a very reasonable,
and a very honest
reply, that said,
I don't expect much
turnover in my areas.
So one of the
ingenious, minor kind
of efforts that this
turned out to be important
was for us to count, to
count ex post every year how
many new appointments we had.
And we surprised our colleagues.
We surprised ourselves
with the fact
that we were making
many more appointments
than we had expected we would
make because there's turnover.
I don't want to say people
die, but that happens too,
both people resign,
people leave.
And so we found
in the areas where
they expected to have
two or three turnover,
not just in the faculty, but
in the administration I'm
talking about, now
when we found that they
had 12 in the past year.
And so one of the things
that we were able to do,
and the reason I bring that up
is because that is the antidote
to excuse is the facts,
you just bring somebody
a piece of paper that
simply says, in your area,
there was so much
turnover last year.
Now you tell us then.
We hired 46 new faculty
members last year.
One of them was minority.
Is that reasonable?
I can stand up in front
of all of my friends, all
of my fellow senior
officers here,
and they will say, well,
that may be excusable,
but it is not very reasonable.
We want more.
So excuses exist.
And they have very good reasons.
And for rational
people, they are very
rational and understandable.
But when they don't give
you the desired result,
they're not good enough.
KEYSER: It's my opinion that the
easiest emotion for us to have,
the easier emotion, is
hate as opposed to love.
Now it's not too hard
to see why it's easier
to hate than to love.
To love requires a
relationship with someone else.
Hate, in fact, doesn't
require a relationship.
In fact, it's much
easier to hate somebody
that you don't know.
What is one of the
properties of hatred?
It seems to me that one of
the properties of hatred
is that it lowers our
unwillingness to act.
Another way to put it
is, what hatred does
is make it far easier for
us to act on impulse rather
than rationally.
Now let me give you
an example of why
I believe that this is something
which is instinctual in us
and that we have to really
be constantly aware of.
When somebody says blood,
we start to resonate.
And we have to say, uh-oh,
that's our basic brain
resonating, let's not listen.
At the very least, let's
get out of the room.
There was a famous
member of the faculty
here by the name of
Jerry Lettvin who
did work on what the frog's
eye tells the frog's brain.
And Jerry discovered
that the frog actually
has five separate independent
neural detectors in its brain.
Basically, these detectors,
each one does a separate thing.
There is a detector
that fires whenever
an edge is introduced into
the frog's field of vision.
There is a detector that fires
whenever a small black object
makes a trajectory toward the
center of an imaginary circle.
There is a detector that
fires whenever light dims.
There's a detector
that fires whenever
there is blue in the vicinity.
There is a detector
that fires whenever
there is any change at all.
These five detectors
are abstract properties
which the frog has
extracted through evolution,
from the real world,
which has made it possible
for it to survive
virtually unchanged for two
million years.
And I will show you why they're
so good at helping the frog
to survive.
When a detector that sees an
edge and a small black dot
fires, the frog eats it because
it's a fly landing on a twig.
Whenever the light dims,
the frog jumps towards blue.
Why?
Because the frog's
enemies attack
with the sun at its back.
And the closer the
enemy gets to the frog,
the less light gets
to the frog's eye.
And what does he do when
he jumps towards blue?
He jumps towards that part
of the world which reflects
the sky, which is water.
Now what's this got
to do with hatred?
In my opinion, hatred
in human beings
is the event
detector in the frog.
When anything ever happens,
the frog is suddenly alert.
Any change at all, the
frog is suddenly alert.
And what suddenly
alert means is,
I'm ready to act
instantaneously,
without thought.
And I believe that
in human beings,
hatred is an event detector
which says, I'm ready to act.
And tribalism is
jumping towards blue.
PARKER: What do
we have to bridge?
And based on that
comment, it was explicit
what we have to bridge, how
to understand other people
cultures, and how
to respect them,
and how can we come together and
synergize all of our energies
as a people, as
Americans, no matter
whether you're Italian
American, African American,
Chinese American, how can we
take that and become a better
America?
So the response was, we
don't know what to do.
How do we start this?
But the best way to do that is,
how do you define yourselves,
and how do other people
define themselves,
and how can we deal with that?
The central part
of the class is not
how much material
you cover, it's
how much conversation
you stimulate.
Because once people start
talking, they open up
and you are able to
understand how they think.
And I think bridging
the gap, the key element
is how other people think,
not what topics are covered.
This type of teaching
should be a staple.
Everybody should have some
multi-ethnic, multicultural
training because that's
what tomorrow is.
And that's what today is.
And I don't think people
are properly prepared.
CHUN: I'm sure I've built
my own boundaries, in a way,
as a biology major, as I
don't know, as being Korean,
and whether just
staying with Koreans,
if I just take a
look at my friends
and I happen to notice
that they're all Korean,
it's provided just a medium for
me to communicate with others
and to realize that,
yes, we have differences,
we can bring our unique
differences together,
and yet we can get along.
And so I'm grateful for that.
And it's just the beginning
of this door opening.
And hopefully, we
talked about how
we're going to be
agents of change
and how we can get a
chain reaction going.
WILLIAMS: About three years
ago, it became very clear to me
that the student
body, particularly
the undergraduate student
body, was so visibly changing
in terms of the
students of color.
And I think that it was
perhaps maybe the first year
that we had a freshman class
that consisted of more than 50%
of students of color and
international students.
And at that time, I did not feel
that we were taking advantage
of this rich culture that
existed, racial and ethnicity,
I would say, here.
And so therefore, I thought that
it would be a very good idea
to begin to give a
seminar based on the fact
that the large
number of students
who were on undergraduate
level did not
appear to me to be communicating
at all with each other.
I'll tell you basically what the
objectives of the seminar are.
And I think that I
have to preface this
by saying that one
of the real issues,
I believe, particularly
in the year 2000,
is the fact that our
young men and women who
will go into the
workforce will have
to learn how to deal with
more women in the workforce
and deal more with the new
workers in the workforce.
I think that minorities will
constitute about one third
of the workforce
in the year 2000.
And also, the
companies, in order
to be internationally
competitive,
are going to have
to be able to deal
with the whole
issue of teamwork,
regardless of who people
are, whether they are handy,
whether they are people
with disabilities,
whether they are women,
whether they are minorities.
So I say all that to say that
the objectives of the course
really is to try to help young
men and women here at MIT
to begin to get ready to
deal with the workforce
in that relationship.
What I really would like to see
is an Institute developed here
at the Institute,
at MIT, that will
do more than just the
course, but be an agency that
will provide lots
of kinds of support
for helping not only students,
but faculty who I think need
a lot of help in understanding
this racial and cultural
differences that
will not go away,
but will increase substantially.
So I think we need a lot
of help to understand
some of the differences that
exist through our students
and hopefully, our faculty.
I'm not sure that equal
opportunity is the right name
anymore.
I'm not even sure that
affirmative action
is the right name.
I think that we need to
look at the whole structure
of this whole effort
and find a better
way of being able to
bring people of color,
and people who
have disabilities,
women back together
more as a team.
And it requires some
other kinds of things
other than talking about the
affirmative action aspect.
I think the numbers are
going to take care of itself
if you can get people
understanding that it has
nothing to do with
the issue of color,
or gender, and some of
the other stereotypes
that I think we have.
And I think that
we need to put more
effort on some other things.
And I think that will
make a difference.
[MUSIC - STEVIE WONDER, "PASTIME
PARADISE"] They've been
spending most their lives
living in a future paradise.
They've been spending
most their lives
living in a future paradise.
They've been looking in
their minds for the day
that sorrows lost from time.
They keep telling of the
day when the savior of love
will come to stay.
Tell me who of them
will come to be.
How many of them are you and me.
Proclamation.
Of race relations.
Consolation.
Integration.
Verification.
Of revelations.
Acclamation.
World salvation.
Vibrations.
Stimulation.
Confirmation, to the
peace of the world.